انطلقت في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض اليوم
اعماله الاجتماع الوزري للتحالف الدولي ضد
تنظيم الدوله يبحث الاجتماع والجهود
الدوليه لمكافحه التنظيم في قاره افريقيا
في غرب وجنوب القاره اضافه الى بحث تقديم
المساعدات العسكريه والاقتصاديه للدول
التي تبذل جهودا في محاربه التنظيم واكد
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتن بلنكن
التزام الولايات المتحده بالقضاء على
الارهاب في العالم بما في ذلك تنظيم
الدوله وشدد على اهميه اعاده توطين
المقاتلين الاجانب للتنظيم لاسيما
الموجودين في مخيم الهول بسوريا بجانبه
قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان التحالف الدوليه منع تنظيم
الدوله من استغلال اي فرصه للعوده مجددا